when advertising began in a significant
way in the early 19th century it was a
relatively straightforward business it
showed you a product told you what it
did where you could get it and what it
cost
then in 1960s America a remarkable new
way of advertising emerged led by
luminaries of Madison Avenue like
William Bernbach David Ogilvy and Mary
Wells Lawrence in their work for brands
like SOA vests and life cereal adverts
cease to be in a narrow sense about the
things that they were selling the focus
of an ad might ostensibly be on a car
but our attention was also being
directed at the harmonious handsome
couple holding hands beside it
it might unsurfaced be in adverted out
soap but the true emphasis was on the
state of calm that accompanied the
washing it might be whiskey one was
being invited to drink but it was the
attitude of resoluteness and resilience
on display that provided the compelling
focal point Madison Avenue had made an
extraordinary discovery however
appealing a product might be there were
many other things that were likely to be
even more appealing to customers and by
in twining their products with these
ingredients sales could be transformed
Patek Phillipe is one of the Giants of
the global watchmaking industry since
1996 they've been running a very
distinctive series of adverts featuring
parents and children it's almost
impossible not to have glimpse one
somewhere in one example a father and
son are hanging out together in scenes
which tenderly evoke filial and paternal
loyalty in love we can imagine the boy
will grow up confident and independent
it also respectful and warm the advert
understands our deepest hopes around our
children it's moving because what it
depicts is so hard to find in real life
we're often brought to tears not so much
by what we have as by what we long for
but cannot reach
father-son relationships are dependably
problematic but in the world of Patek
Phillipe we glimpse a kind of
psychological paradise we can turn to
Calvin Klein the couple seemed like they
might have been together a while they
may have a couple of children and
they're in it for the long term the
perfume is called eternity but their
passion is still so intense they have
sex maybe a couple of times a day often
in unusual locations Calvin Klein knows
all about what we really want in
relationships it's brilliantly latched
on to our deepest and at the same time
our most elusive in a long house adverts
wouldn't work if they didn't operate
with a very good understanding of what
our real needs are what we truly require
to be happy their emotional pull is
based on knowingness
eerily well as they recognize we are
creatures who hunger for good family
relationships connections with others a
sense of freedom and joy a promise of
self-development dignity calm and the
feeling that we're respected yet armed
with this knowledge they and the
corporation's who bankroll them are
unwittingly somewhat cruel to us for
while they excite us with reminders of
our Buried longings they cannot do
anything wholehearted about quenching
them adverts may want to sell us things
but incommensurate things in relation to
the hopes they've aroused Calvin Klein
makes lovely Cologne Patek Phillipe
swatches are extremely reliable in
beautiful agents of timekeeping but
these items cannot by themselves help us
secure the goods are unconscious
believed were on offer the real crisis
of capitalism is the product development
lags so far behind the best insights of
advertising since the 1960's advertising
has worked out just how much we need
help with the true challenges of life
its fathomed how deeply we want to have
better careers stronger relationships
greater confidence in most adverts the
pain and the hope of our lives have been
superbly identified but the products are
almost comically at odds with the
problems at hand
advertisers are hardly to blame they are
in fact the victims of an extraordinary
oblem of modern capitalism while we have
so many complex needs
we have nothing better to offer
ourselves in the face of our troubles
then perhaps a slightly more accurate
chronometer or a more subtly blended
perfume business needs to get more
ambitious in the creation of new kinds
of products in their own way as
strange-sounding today as a wristwatch
would have struck observers in 1500 we
need the drive of Commerce to get behind
filling the world in our lives with
goods that really can help us to thrive
flourish find contentment and manage our
relationships well to trace the future
shape of capitalism we only have to
think of all the needs we have that
currently lie outside of commerce we
need help in forming cohesive
interesting benevolent communities we
need help in bringing up children we
need help in calming down at key moments
we require immense assistance in
discovering our real talents in the
workplace our higher needs are not
trivial or minor once insignificant
things we could easily survive without
they are in many ways central to our
lives we've simply accepted without
adequate protest that there is nothing
business could sell us to address them
we don't know today quite what the
businesses of the future will look like
just as half a century ago no one could
describe the corporate essence of the
current large technology companies but
we can know the direction we need to
head to one where the drive and
inventiveness of capitalism tackles the
higher deeper problems of life
advertising has at least done as the
great service at hinting at the future
shape of the economy it already trades
on all the right ingredients the
challenge now is to narrow the gap
between the fantasies being offered and
what businesses should be able to sell
us
you